Шановні колеги Дорогі українській
народи Сьогодні підранок я повернувся з
фронту і
сказати про те що там не вистачає
снарядів нічого не сказати це те що
кажуть наші
бійці сказати що не вистачає проти
повітряної оборони нічого не сказати і
ми маємо зробити все можливе для того
щоби прискорити надання від наших
партнерів цієї допомоги і держава має
налагодити серійне виробництво всередині
країни але є речі які ми в парламенті і
виконавчій владі можемо зробити прямо
зараз перша позиція - це fпві дрони
Вчора ми відвезли сотні Дронів а
виявляється і я прошу перевірити цю
інформацію запросивши керівника дстзі
десятки тисячвпіві Дронів зараз на дах
дестзїв це є злочин який має бути
покараний А ми маємо зробити все для
того щоби збільшити виробництво пві і
доставити це в кожний батальйон друге
треба налагодити виробництво реб я
Нагадую що моя команда інвестувала 150
млні грвень в розробку нової технології
яка вже зараз садить орлани і
суперками третя позиція
це прискорення будівництва глибоко
ошелонованих фортифікаційних споруд хочу
нагадати що в 14-му 15 роках кожен
губернатор був відповідальний за свою
ділянку фронту і в повному обсязі було
профінансовано з державного бюджету
будівництва 3 мльна за кожний опорний
пункт і було перша друга і третя лінія і
зараз це має бути питання державної воги
за д-три місяці ми маємо завершити цей
процес четверте ми маємо засіяти там всю
територію мінами щоби не кров'ю
українських воїнів зупиняти російський
наступ і друга позиція це є єдність
єдність навколо збройних сил України і
нам потрібно щоби не словом а діями
Верховна Рада підтримала цю єдність
перше треба поставити на голосування
законопроект який вимагав би погодження
з
головнокомандувачем призначення
командуючих бо це про відповідальність
друге поставити на голосування проект
постанови вініславського про очищення
комітету з нацбезпеки від неадекватної
особи яка поплюжить збройні сили України
і і дуже важливо поставити законопроект
про церкву бо це теж про нацбезпеку Коли
у нас керує церква країни
Слава Україні